want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't procrastinate with bill gates
i had one habit that uh i developed when
i when i was
at college that was actually very bad
habit which was
i like to show people that i didn't do
any work uh and that i didn't go to
classes and i didn't care and then at
the very last minute uh like two days
before the test i'd get serious about it
and and people
people thought that was funny uh you
know that was my positioning the guy who
did nothing until the last minute then
when i went into business that was a
really bad habit
and it took me a couple years to get
over that nobody praised me because i i
would do things at the last minute and i
tried to reverse
to students i'd actually uh i didn't
think that highly of who were always
organized and had things done on time
i'm still working on it but uh
procrastination is not a good good habit
rule number two use your voice with
oprah winfrey i think some people think
that are under the impression that i was
born empowered that i was born
coming out of the womb ready to
interview a klansman
then cut to commercial we'll be right
back
but the truth is
i know very well what it's like to be
marginalized to be told either
subtly or quite directly that my
contribution
isn't or wasn't welcome
that my face was invisible and that my
needs were an affront so back when i was
doing the news in baltimore i asked to
be paid the same as my co-anchor who did
exactly the same job as i was doing and
i
expected that i would be compensated so
i went in and i asked that i would get
the same amount of money so he was doing
the same job i was doing except that he
called me babe all the time babe yeah
babe
anyway i was told by my news director
and by the general manager because first
i went to the news director then i was
general manager and i was told that
because i was a single woman
who didn't have a mortgage and i didn't
have kids that i was not entitled to
earn the same kind of money as the man
who was sitting next to me
doing the same thing
and i realized in that moment that my
employers did not get it they did not
understand my value
but you know what i did
so cut to am chicago the team's hard at
work
and they had been working for a long
time
and after a year or so
we were asked to be syndicated that work
began to pay off and before long we were
now no longer called am chicago or the
national oprah winfrey show i got a
raise this is before i own myself
so
i got a raise
but my producers did not so i went into
the boss at the time
and i asked that my producers who
incidentally were all female
i asked that they would be given a pay
raise increase
and my boss
this is in 1986 said why
they're only girls
what do they need more money for
girls
uh i've used the word affectionately
sometimes referring to women as girls
and
there was no affection in his tone it
was absolutely condescending so
uh
you know it takes a while to develop a
voice but once you have it you damn sure
better use it on stuff that matters
so i took a deep breath in that moment
and said
either
they're going to get raises
or i'm going to sit down
i'm not going to work if they don't get
paid more
babe
[Music]
now
i would like to believe that i could
have spoken that kind of truth to
misogyny even if i'd been all by myself
but here i was on the brink of finally
getting what i really wanted and had
been working uh many years for a
national show
i mean i might have been too intimidated
to stand my own ground against this guy
if i were actually alone but here's the
thing you're never alone
you're never alone
the sovereign sound of maya angelou's
voice
was pushing me forward that day
whispering
i come as one
but i stand as ten thousand
so when i was faced with the opportunity
to advocate for my producers
i silently called on some of the ten
thousand
and walked into my boss's office
hand in spirit
with the women who had come before me
i could feel betsy smith
and billy
an ella fitzgerald and pearl bailey and
sarah vaughan and lena horn clutching
their green books looking for a place to
eat while they sang in supper clubs for
whites only
and i could feel reese taylor and rosa
parks refusing to relinquish their
dignity in the face of death threats all
these women were with me that day
walking into the office in chicago as
was diana carroll and petula clark and
joan baez and mary tyler moore and mom's
maybelli and barbara walters and all of
the astonishing women whose names none
of us will ever even know despite their
sacrifice and i'm pretty sure
i even heard shirley chisholm
urging me on with this thought
if they don't give you a seat at the
table
bring a folding chair
and i understood
i understood that there were so many
times that many women from my mother's
generation and god knows my
grandmother's generation who were forced
to grit their teeth and just take it
because standing up for themselves
wasn't even an option
the risk was too great
and they knew it
but they also knew in their bones what
my dear friend maya
put so eloquently into words when she
says you may not control all the events
that happened to you
but you can decide not to be reduced by
them
because these women and so many others
like them made the decision not to allow
themselves to be reduced by the many
injustices they were subjected to
i found the strength to act if not just
for myself
not just for my producers but for all
the women who in their ingenious ways
subverted the rules laid the foundation
and pushed the envelope just a little
bit further for me rule number three
create something exciting with elon musk
you think about the future you want a
future that's better than the past and
so if we had something like the
hyperloop i think that would be like
cool like you'd look forward to the day
that that was working
you know and and it's something like
that even if it was only iota only
was in one place you know from l.a san
francisco or new york to
dc or something like that then um
it would be cool enough that it would be
like a tourist attraction yeah like a
riot yeah yeah so so even if if um some
of the initial assumptions didn't work
out and economics didn't didn't work out
quite as as one expected it would be
like cool enough like i want to journey
that place just to just to write on that
thing that would be pretty cool um
and
so that's i think how if you cope with a
new technology it should feel like that
you should really
like if you told it to an objective
person would they look forward to the
day that that thing became available
yeah and like you know be pretty
exciting to to do something like that
um or an aircraft like i thought it was
really disappointing when the when the
concorde was taken out of commission and
there was no supersonic uh transport
available
and of course the 787 has had some
issues yeah um
so
um
but it's but the thing is the 787 even
the best case scenario is only a
slightly better version of the triple
seven yeah um
and it's like okay
not that exciting
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four keep working
backwards with jeff bezos we would all
love all of our numbers to be smooth
lines up and to the right and that would
be terrific but that's not how it works
you know
you know the those numbers are
are output
measures and you i mean i guess you
could try to manage your quarterly
earnings very precisely but i i think
personally that would be a mistake you
know most of
the work that we put into um
any particular quarter happened years
ago so it's not you know there's there
aren't that many knobs you can turn
during a quarter i mean you can but
they're very they're like eating your
seed corn if you turn those knobs you
don't want to do that and so
uh it's it's uh
i you know people
i think if you focus on the controllable
inputs to your business instead of the
outputs in the long term you get better
results so the the benchman graham quote
here is that in the
short term the stock market is a voting
machine in the long term it's a weighing
machine and i think people are well
advised to build a company that wants to
be weighed and not voted upon
and that means having good return on
invested capital and having you know
lots of free cash flow but if you said
to me if i said
here's a job i would reject if somebody
came to me and said jeff i want your job
to be to
drive up the amazon stock price
and just manage that directly now this
might sound ridiculous to some of you
but many companies actually do this they
have they actually go out and they try
to sell the stock that's kind of the
final output
and it's much better to say okay
let's not do that that's not going to be
sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
what are the inputs to a higher stock
price and he said okay well pre-cash
flow and return on invested capital
inputs to a higher stock price okay so
let's let's keep working backwards what
are the inputs to free cash flow and you
keep working backwards until you get to
something that's controllable
and a controllable input
for free cash that would be something
like lower cost structure and they back
up from there and you say okay well you
know if we can improve our picking
efficiency in our fulfillment centers
and reduce defects defects are very very
costly it's probably you know reducing
defects at the root is one of the best
ways to lower cost structure
and so
if you then that starts to be a job you
would accept you would say if you're you
know a reasonable person you would say i
have no idea how to
uh drive up the stock price i can't
manage that directly it's not a
controllable input but i can make your
picking algorithms more efficient
and that will reduce cost structure and
then you know follow that chain all
along the way
that's what you do
in all of these businesses rule number
five care about people with richard
branson the key the the key to i think
being a good um business leader is is
your is how good you are with people i
think if you can
care genuinely care about people
um
not just your fellow directors but you
know the cleaning lady the switchboard
operator you know everybody throughout
the company
um you know if you're a good you know if
you know if you praise and don't
criticize um
uh you know people people will flourish
um and
uh so i think you know it it it's really
your people skills that will set you set
you apart
um
and
uh and
uh and and i don't think that can be
over over emphasized i think um just you
just got to
um you know if i get if i'm on a virgin
plane i will make sure that i always
have a notebook in my back pocket
um you know make sure i get out and talk
to all the staff
you know if they've got issues you know
make sure i don't just you know hear the
issue and not write it down make sure
those issues get written down rule
number six don't limit yourself with
grant cardone unfortunately because we
have so much attention on our physical
capacity and limitations five eight
you know i've been a little guy my whole
life got to feed myself three times a
day because i'm hungry i gotta urinate
you know sometimes with my buddy
um i gotta i gotta i gotta sleep
nine hours a day eight to nine hours a
day i'm reminded i'm a body
which has been a deception for me
because that's not what i'm i'm not
limited to just that and so it's been a
big trick
thinking oh i just got to take care of
this i got to clothe it i got to protect
it i got to worry about it the older you
get the more you worry about it kids can
do almost anything
you know kids can jump off a freaking
they can jump out of a car roll around
on the damn grass and pop up and say
yeah that was fun let's do that again
you do that to me man i'm like dang that
hurt right so you can see a kid flying
down the mountain at 70 miles an hour
man i'm i'm terrified because i'm gonna
break something so it's that
it's that concern about me as a like is
something gonna happen to me
if i wouldn't have been concerned about
myself
my god i could have done anything man i
would have already done it
so so that's how i would just that's
been a big limitation what what ed's
talking about the the capacity of the
individual is
i don't think i've even like remotely
scratched
hopefully if i come back if i can come
back if anybody believes in that kind of
stuff like then i can come back with oh
my god man maybe i'm not just five eight
170 pounds you know little little tiny
little tiny ones got some good guns
right now okay
but maybe i can do more than just the
physical limitations that that that i
impose on myself and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is create change with mark
cuban what industry you think still
requires a lot of innovation
all of them
seriously i mean look
one of my dad's favorite sayings was you
don't live in the world you were born
into everything changes all the time and
you know what's better than change
creating change and so whenever i see
something that's done the way it's
always been done
you know like when i got to the mba
you know my whole goal is just to have
things up right because they everything
was done the exact same way they thought
they were in the business of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no you when you
go to a basketball game you don't
remember the jump shots the dunks you
remember who you were with the fun you
had it's one of the few industries when
that ball is in the air at the end of a
game
everybody holds their breath and your if
it goes in you're hugging people you've
never seen before you you know so you
can take any industry and look at the
way things have been done and try to
come up and innovate and
you know and like i said with just the
nature of capitalism right now all the
changes that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that i don't think
any generation has ever seen now i've
got a special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you if you think you're like what is
education like you're basically
downloading data and algorithms into
your brain
and
it's it's actually
amazingly bad in conventional education
because like it shouldn't be like this
huge chore um
so you're making it way way better
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of the things that i would say you've
probably heard 100
times
and an effect are if not
doing like the more you can gamify
the uh the process of learning the
better like
for my kids i do not have to encourage
them to play video games yeah okay yeah
i have to like pry them from their hands
like like crack yes yes like drop that
crack needle yeah yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack isn't addictive
um
so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow learning like a
game but that then it's better um
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion um
you've got
uh you know someone standing up there
kind of lecturing at people
um and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it and that lack of
enthusiasm you know is conveyed to the
students that they're not very excited
about it they don't know why they're
there like why are we learning this
stuff we don't even know why um in fact
i think a lot of things people learn
probably there's no point in learning
them um
because they never use them in the
future because who's going to launch a
rocket into space i mean that's just
like yeah yeah exactly that never
happens
um well you have to say like
people i think don't stand back and say
well why are we teaching people these
things
and we should tell them probably why
we're teaching these things because a
lot of kids are just in school kind of
puzzled as to why they're there
yeah um
and i think if you can explain the why
of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand
they understand purpose yeah um
so i think that's pretty important so at
what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said hmm like
let's do this like what was the well we
were planning to do it because i knew
the business i was in marketing sales
and structure and had connections with
uh product development
and i didn't do hair paul was a great
hairdresser one of the best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was the perfect
combination for these two guys together
we're just the best of friends and we
knew we could do it uh obviously we
started out with nothing we made the
decision let's just let's just make this
happen and as you will see and your
guests will see when they look at good
fortune the movie and it's on itunes
it's on amazon all those when you look
at it it's the whole story of starting
in america with nothing a couple times
and making things happen because of what
you believe in but the important thing
is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do not
shake your hand to that sure you betcha
but i applaud you that's awesome it's
still going on that one it's been
a lot of fun you know there's tons of
things that i'm not good at
and so the question is always can i get
somebody involved you know
you know certain day-to-day management
things negotiating things political
things scientific experts who really do
have the time to focus in on one thing
like i did in in my twenties and just
really really see all the the
possibilities nobody's journey is
seamless or smooth we all stumble we all
have setbacks if things go wrong you hit
a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend eckhart tolle
uh who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth it's all about
letting the awareness of who you are
stimulate everything that you do he puts
it like this he says don't react against
a bad situation merge with that
situation instead and the solution will
arise from the challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i always tell people
sometimes i get you know we'll have a
good um
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working on a quarter
that's going to
reveal itself in 2021 sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know two or
three years in advance
and um if you are and then why do i need
to make 100 decisions today if i make
like three good decisions a day that's
enough are there any leadership
principles um
you know that that have contributed to
your success as a leader not as an
entrepreneur
leader does never fix the style
right some leaders good speaking some
leader never speak by actions
leader leadership doesn't have a stat
everybody can be a leader a good leader
should have a vision
the vision is that vision not
necessarily good because when i work in
the company
when everybody was disappointed i have
to tell them i have to see before the
other people see the opportunity where
everybody excited i have to see the
disaster
especially as a ceo of like a me an
alibaba group my job is to see the
problems of the future
so
and kill the
problems before the disaster comes so a
leader must have a vision how do you
deal with failure and what's your advice
to young entrepreneurs like me in this
case especially with regards to failure
and how to approach it yeah well if
if you fail you really do dust yourself
off and you know get right back in i
mean you're going to fail at some things
uh uh
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out uh you
know
fairly significant number of people get
divorced i mean and you know that's a
very big decision to have turn out badly
but uh
i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history and
you'll everybody
fails at some things i mean you know
particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just knowing about whatever maybe
businesses uh but you know it it is not
fatal i mean if you're healthy
and
you live in this particular living in
this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was when i got
out of the university of nebraska you
know and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you traveled on the train and so i spent
10 hours going there and this fellow
looked at me and about 10 minutes he
said you know forget it bell
and now i've got to go back on the train
10 hours and think
what am i going to tell my dad what i
want to tell my dad i mean my dad always
told me i could do anything and
everything now i've just got just gotten
turned down uh you know but it turned
out that one of the best things ever
happened to me because then i went to
columbia where ben graham was it in fact
it probably even affected who i married
because i took a one-year course at
columbia and said two years at harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time
almost everything in my life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually it's turned into a success
i mean it
it the world isn't over you know
if you have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but but
the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and you know
you've got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know
the world isn't over yet you know you
just go out
and find somebody else i remember
distinctly i had this one friend um who
i went and got pizza with almost every
night we did all our computer science
problem sets together
at harvard and
at the time i remember talking to him
about
how
i was working on this facebook thing and
i thought it would be cool for harvard
and i really was excited about it
because i wanted to use it but at the
same time how i thought that over time
someone would definitely go build this
version of this for the world but it
wasn't going to be us it was going to be
you know microsoft or you know someone
who built software for hundreds of
millions of people it's like who we were
college students right we're not
qualified in any way to build this and
you know i think a lot of my takeaway
from that was that we just kind of cared
more than those other companies about
making it exist i feel like hustle is um
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also your willingness to
get the job done like um kind of
navigating and doing what it takes
and um
and so
i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome or my success
be contingent on other people as much as
i can control it help it navigate it i'm
going to
so um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now i mean obviously i'm hustling
i'm like at the at this where i am now
and i'm running around the airport
asking people to follow me on instagram
you know uh i just feel like it's innate
in me also to a degree um but
the uh in the beginning ex like there's
a few examples that come to mind you
mentioned that i paid my i called my
friends and asked them to go buy spanx
and i wrote everybody checks and sent
them a check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i need to to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then i immediately
went to
target and i bought
envelope dividing dividers that you put
on your home desk and i ran around
neiman marcus and put them at every
register and i put spanx in them and
then i walked away
and
neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and
and i did that because i had to get my
product out of the department and
because i did that women in shoes
started buying spanx and women in
contemporary
and
those decisions made such a big
difference and by the time somebody
figured out that nobody else had
approved it because you know everybody
thought somebody else approved it
um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it during my
california springs and summers i spent
most of my days in the high sierras in
yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i had learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but it was fun
and i was good at it
and computer program programming gave me
the same kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife
was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
this was a pivotal moment in my
[Applause]
life my family was still mad at me for
not going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again a lot of people think that spanx
started when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but actually it started long
before that it started when i was
selling fax machines door to door
and getting my car business card ripped
up in my face being escorted out of
buildings all day every day that i woke
up one day and just thought
i'm in the wrong movie like how did this
happen this is not my life cut scene
director like call the producer and i
got out a piece of paper and i wrote
down what am i good at and the only
thing in the good column was sales and i
thought okay what am i going to do with
that and i ended up writing in my
journal i'm going to invent a product
and sell it to millions of people that
will make them feel good and then i
asked the universe for an idea and i was
very specific and it took two years
and i only cut the feet out of my
pantyhose one time and i was not going
to squander any idea the universe gave
me because i had really asked for it
and then the minute i cut the feet out i
started trying to make it i started
looking up
manufacturers on the internet this is
before alibaba wasn't it
yes i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which was a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
wall yes and i was i always every time i
went around turned around and went back
home because i was too scared i had
crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city uh on long island in
the 80s when break dancing and rap and
all this stuff was happening yep and i
was really into break dancing i don't
know i don't look like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money probably if i went to
washington dc you know because the kids
in washington dc couldn't be as good as
the kids in new york we invented this
whole genre so i got my friend myron
who's my partner my sister just got her
driver's license and i convinced her to
drive us to washington dc and the whole
drive down i was having all that
self-doubt yeah you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and i stink yeah and so i
was almost talking myself out i was
building the wall of doubt up brick by
brick in my own head yeah and when we
got there we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and a crowd
gathered around and ultimately after i
did my thing more people came i took my
hat i passed it around we made about 200
i paid my sister for the gas money and
then myron and i split 82. 41 each and
this guy you know he's counting up the
money and he's counting up the money and
he gets all the money and then he
sprints over to me and he gives me a
bear hug and he goes jess
[Laughter]
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall and i realized i
could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that what
was called beautiful
i didn't see myself in right and so i
had this whole idea which is part of why
all the retailers were saying no in the
early years i had this idea to not just
create products that work but let me
show
models all different people every age
skin tone skin challenge gender identity
skin problem size like let me just show
real people and prove this product works
like let me go on qvc and prove it live
let me show my own rosation i just
thought if people can see people look
like them this just makes sense to me
but all the experts said it didn't so
so back to me standing there with this
investor saying i don't think people
will buy makeup from someone who looks
like you with your body and your weight
after i went in my car and cried
like it's rejection always still hurts
uh i also just remember feeling like wow
he's passing on investing in my business
on he's making a business decision
because
of exactly why i'm starting this company
like he's just as much
i don't want to call it a victim but
just as much
impacted by
by the definition of beauty that's out
there
and he's literally passing on investing
in my company because of it
and so it drove my deep why for like why
i was building this company
and i took that rejection as fuel for
like oh this has got to change right and
for me it was like let me build a
company
where we show all types of beauty where
where it wasn't even just about selling
product it wasn't about solving my own
problems and even though i want to help
millions of women and all that
the real why was like can i shift
culture and beauty
um for every little girl out there
who's about to start doubting herself
and every grown person who still does
and so like that drive
fueled it and
not being afraid of rejection is so huge
and it's it's really huge for women
because it prevents a lot of people from
even trying
and it hurts the general theme i would
suggest is that all trends um are
overrated
and so uh if you think about current uh
trends in technology uh you know uh
uh
healthcare i.t software education
software overrated
sas enterprise software really overrated
big data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can um and um and the reason these
buzzwords
um
tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords they're sort of
like a tell in poker that people are
bluffing and that there's nothing that
there's uh that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore
are symptomatic somehow of of
a lot of competition and a bad a bad
business idea and so you know you don't
want to be the fourth online pet food
company you don't want to be the 10th
thin film solar panel company you don't
want to be the 1000th restaurant in san
francisco and so there is something
about if you can describe
what a company is doing
very straightforwardly by referencing
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist
that's actually a sign that it's a
pretty bad uh that's that's a pretty bad
idea you mentioned that
whilst writing 10x raw something changed
for you yeah yeah
what was that was it was that sort of
this look the 10x rule to going all in
or no the 10x were also it was just the
awareness of i had been dependent upon
one vertical
right and i'm sitting there looking okay
i worked my ass off
uh i i was good at my craft
i saved my money
what did i do wrong here dude
51 years old
i should have
i should be like so rich right now
i got i mean i should be like not even
huh where's my jet i wasn't even
thinking about injecting right i wasn't
even thinking about jet i should just be
like
i was still having to do business with
people i didn't like
i'm like why am i still kissing asses
and i don't mind kissing asses like i
don't mind i'll do whatever it takes but
i'm like
why am i still flying three million
miles every three years like i was
banging miles down i wasn't 150 000
miles a year wow you know away from my
family like like my life was miserable
i'm like
it's fine that you do that for 20 years
it's not fine if you do it forever and
i'm like oh my god dude i wasn't scaling
now i didn't know that until the economy
um basically served up the lesson right
all right we're gonna take your three
businesses and we're gonna show you that
we you really only have like maybe
a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90 percent like
just killed this partner i had
and the third business was real estate
and it was frozen it was literally like
they put it in a freezer and said you
can't you're not gonna lose any of this
but it's worth nothing to you today yeah
and i was a life support
and i'm like i'll never do this again i
will never be dependent upon
one vertical one partner
or a handful of real estate i have three
real estate properties i think there's a
problem in in western europe where um
where failure is uh it's it's too
impossible to fail once you fail you can
never you can never start over i think
there's a there's an opposite version of
this in california where i think
sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people um
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um
uh
that's you know that's that's going to
be
psychologically damaging you know people
have less confidence you all sorts of
reasons why why that tends to be uh that
tends to be quite bad i think that um i
think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you worked with the
wrong people the idea was bad the timing
was wrong it wasn't a monopoly the
product didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again so i think i think failure is
not something one can learn very much
from i think that's sort of a myth that
i i would challenge um but what i think
what i think you should do when you when
when something goes badly wrong is um
you just keep going uh you you do
something else uh and you don't dwell on
the past i think when dreams start to
brew in us or when there's like a seed
planted in us where we have this dream
it kind of started that way where i was
like like it was like a little inkling
like wait a minute if i if i could
figure out how to launch how to create a
product that works for me i better help
a lot of other people yeah and then i
would kind of like silence that dream
and i would my head would take over oh
jamie you have no connections you have
barely any money you don't know anything
about the beauty industry
and you're you're in your dream job
right now right and so it was i went
through that battle and i think everyone
listening to us right now probably like
really if they get still they probably
know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they know
what they're supposed to create fear is
a really powerful thing
but when you surrender and say i'm not
scared of fear it's unbelievably
liberating now i don't like to be
embarrassed
but i'm not scared of it but it wasn't
always like that for me when i was a
senior in uh
college
there was a girl that i liked i had to
have my roommate in college
call her up
and ask her to go to the formal as me he
literally called up said hey this is
jesse
that fast forward 20 years
i like this girl
i'm trying to court her
she's the founder of spanx
i call the phone i call the her
assistant at spanx
and this is the same time that i'm about
to run a 100 mile race non-stop
in 24 hours for charity i call up i get
to the assistant and i said uh can you
tell sarah that i would love to wear
spanx
if in this 100 mile race if she would
give me a testimonial from my website
i don't want a testimonial i wanted
sarah
obviously the assistant goes hold on one
second puts me on hold and says sarah
there's some lunatic on the phone that
wants to run a hundred miles
in spanx
she says i think i might know that
lunatic
and a year later she married the lunatic
but in between that time when my
roommate had a call
to ask this girl for a date
to when i got sarah i call it like the
lamb mentality and the lion mentality
there was a lot of self-doubt
and self-doubt
is probably the biggest enemy to
creativity and the way you conquer
self-doubt is by doing things that make
you uncomfortable and i'm gonna tell you
something that a lot of people 99 of
people disagree with me on
right everybody says follow your
passions
i say this bull
right i say follow your effort
it's amazing how we're all passionate
about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great
but
no matter what it all nets out to where
do you put your time because when people
put in their time you get better at
things and when you get better at
something and get good at something then
you have a chance to be great at
something and you know what i've learned
nobody ever quits anything they're great
at
and once you get great at it's amazing
how passionate you become about it
follow your efforts
right because it's not in the dreaming
it's in the doing recently you shared in
a press conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked
will you just share what you meant by
that
yeah i mean
look it's
let's be real here i'm not i'm not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've
been planning for this i'm excited about
it and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds so i mean
look when when i got started with
facebook i was 19.
and um
and i there were so many parts about
building a company that i didn't know
right i didn't know anything about
hiring or managing or building a company
and i certainly didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i'm i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um and uh
you know my experience you know kind of
growing up and running the company is
you know went out talked about what we
did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like kind of go into a
into a shell right and and uh end up
being really cautious about how we
communicate
so
you know it kind of it worked out okay
for a while for the company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well i
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time
the basic approach was okay let's try to
not like
do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing in broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
i really believe in helping to build
community and and bring people closer
together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that um some of the
principles that we believe in that that
um that are increasingly controversial
in the world and
i just think that we
for one don't have that luxury anymore
um for two uh i i think that that kind
of led for a while to a sentiment
towards the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then you know it's not
possible for people to feel that
strongly about what you're doing but so
now you know i i've just i've tried to
change our approach more recently you
know i went out and i in georgetown last
year i gave this speech around our
principles around free expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now if you were to do it
all over again you're in our shoes what
industry would that be in where would
you start your own business today
i'd do the same thing yeah i mean
for one thing i'd be a failure to
anything else probably
no i mean i've had
i had fun when i was in my 20s my 30s
now i'm 86 i'm having fun and so i i
advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job i mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life and don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know i'll do this and i'll do that and
you know i'm just marking time to get to
be older that i've told people that's
like saving up sex for your old age i
mean it just is not
it
it's not a good idea yeah
what are you urging them to do
i'll explain it
guess what i'm talking about
now it
it
you just yeah you really want to be
doing what you love doing and you can't
necessarily find it on your first job
right but don't give up before you find
it first as a technology company
we believe in technology is great for
human beings
we believe technology can create a lot
of jobs
because human beings every technology
revolution create more jobs
but when the early stage every
technology
create worries
worry if you do not manage them well
it's going to be a big problem as i said
the first world war because of the first
technology revolution
second technology revolution caused the
second world war
and this is the third technology of
which we're coming
then
as
alibaba we believe in the future we
believe technology will be inclusive
sustainable
and the people worry about environment
using technology
to solve the environment problems we
only have one earth this is we advise we
only have one
well people using
oil coast
if we think earth is um
it's a human i'm a student of
observation i i observe things i
remember being being selling cars saying
this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right
customer the 12 steps right and then i'm
like if i do 12 steps with everybody i
can't get 30 units a
month and then i'm like i started
skipping steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those ten car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had what they what they were
going to ask me for anyway right can i
get you a price a payment a down payment
a monthly payment can i get you
everything you need right i knew that it
was just a matter of about 30 seconds
they were going to ask for it all no
doubt so i just basically intercepted
the customer sped up the processes and
and then i'm like man i i started
hitting 30 36 units 31 units in 14 days
i'm like this is the way to do it and
then when i lost my job because the
dealer wasn't big enough didn't think
big enough himself didn't 10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
um
i went out and started teaching that we
have always had it's been from the very
very beginning you can go back and read
our 1997 shareholder letter uh and the
the core of the company is customer
obsession
as opposed to competitor obsession and
that works really well for us it's a
i think that the advantage of being
customer focused is that customers are
always dissatisfied they always want
more and so they pull you along if
you're trying to serve them they pull
you along
whereas if you're competitor obsessed
if you're a leader if you're the leader
you know you can kind of look around and
you see everybody running behind you
maybe you slow down a little and
customers are always pulling you
so i think if you want to be pioneering
if you want to be inventive
if you want a culture that is
experimental then you want to be
customer obsessed rather than competitor
obsessed today oracle employs around 150
000 people
but when i started
it was not my intention
to build a big company
what happened
well at first we did exactly what we set
out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team
plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company
i call it a crazy idea
because at the time
everyone told me it was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published and ibm was building a
prototype in their research labs
but back then the collective wisdom of
computer experts
was that
while relational databases could be
built
they would never be fast enough to be
useful
i thought all those so-called computer
experts
were wrong
and when you start telling people
that all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates
when people start telling you
that you're crazy you just might be on
to the most important innovation in your
life and think about the various
problems that we were facing or what
would most likely change the future um
the when they were in college there were
five things that i thought would be
um
i mean i thought these were actually
these these i would not regard this as a
profound insight but rather an obvious
one
uh
the
the internet would fundamentally change
humanity because it's it's like uh
humanity would become more of a super
organism because the internet is like
the nervous like nervous system um now
suddenly any part of the human
human organisms
anywhere would have access to all the
information amazing instantly zero link
if you didn't have a nervous system
you wouldn't know what's going on your
fingers wouldn't know what's going on
your toes wouldn't know what's going on
you'd have to do it by diffusion um
and yeah and the way information used to
work was really by diffusion one human
would have to call another human or or
write them yes like if it was a letter
you would have to write like you'd have
to have that letter to another human
that would be carried through a bunch of
things find another person would give it
to you
extremely slow diffusion
um and if you wanted access to books if
you're not did not have a library you're
not you don't have it that's it
so
um
now you have access to all the books
instantly
um and
you if you can be in a remote like
you know mountain top jungle location or
something and have access to
all of humanity's information if you've
got a link to the internet
this was a fundamental profound change
are you ready to allow abundance and
blessings people can't figure out how i
got to be so successful it is because i
have lived in the space of spirit my
whole life my favorite
bible verse because i am christian uh is
acts
something
i used to note a number but this is an
axe y'all can google it
but it says
thank you 17 28.
in god i live and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution
there is a spiritual solution why
because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience you made an interesting
decision when you started uh microsoft
not to have dual a dual class chair and
so many of these silicon valley
companies do today
what do you think of that i think it's a
mistake and i've said that to everyone
who's asked me it's enough as an
individual to really feel like
you're responsible for the success of
the company to actually go and short
circuit the governance mechanism where
if you really are making mistakes that
your board can't outvote you that you
literally can just replace the board the
next day
how kind of hubris is that i mean if
you're really doing a good job you
really think you're at risk of that i
didn't want i felt enough responsibility
for making sure microsoft succeeded that
i didn't want to be the dictator of
microsoft i have had before co-partners
in some businesses i've tried and not as
good as my partner paul mitchell but in
other businesses and they didn't turn
out to be what i thought they would be
so if you have a partner one you've got
to be friendly to one another you also
have to have your boundaries where okay
i live my life you live your life we
can't live it all together we're
together we have a certain goal now if
you do have i call it a challenge
opposed to a problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively it was don't
attack on it instead it's much easier to
say
well you know liz uh
you're a wonderful person we've done
some really great business together but
with all due respect when i came in here
i had a great idea wanted to tell you
and you kept on cutting me off and it
made me feel bad liz you know as well it
just made me feel bad and i know you'd
like to hear it i just wanted to share
that with you you share your feelings
with the person if they have an idea you
don't think it's any good you can say
you know that's that that that's a great
idea i could appreciate where you're
coming from always validate the person
however can we look at this a little
differently maybe we can enhance it and
build upon it and you come in with your
two cents always respect the other
person
[Music]
if you want even more wisdom from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we don't love this product but we
think others will love it you know
that's not really how it works if you
don't love it don't expect others will
either your relationship with time is
such a key component
of your life